[Música]
[Aplausos]
se requiere buen talento
memoria y entendimiento fuerza de gallo
castizo
cual vendaval de granizos ande florear
los vocablos
se ha de asombrar hasta el
con muchas bellas razones como las
conversaciones entre sampeiro y san
pablo
también señores oyentes se necesita
instrumentos muchísimos elementos y un
compañero lo cuente
ha de ser buen contendiente conocedor de
la historia quisiera tener buena memoria
para entablar un desafío
pero no me da el sentido para finalizar
con gloria
y para cantar la porfía habrá que ser
toca ahora arrogante la cantora para
seguir melodía
garantizar alegría mientras dure el
contrapunto
formar un bello conjunto responder con
gran destreza
yo no sé si mi cabeza
es capaz para este asunto
y
no no
no no no
cuando fui a la pampa lleva para mi
corazón contento como un tiny ue pero ya
se me murió primero perdí las plumas y
luego perdí la voz y arriba quemando el
sol
cuando te de los dineros dentro de su
habitación me dije mejor a mí también su
concha el caracol o a la sombra de las
leyes el refinado ladrón y arriba
quemando el sol
las hileras de casuchas frente a frente
sí señor las hileras de mujeres frente
al único pilón cada una con su balde y
su cara de aflicción y arriba quemando
el sol
pasa por
no puede esto se me nubla y ahora
aunque donde habita gente la muerte
mucho peor enterraron la justicia y
enterraron la razón y arriba quemando el
sol
si alguien dice que yo sueño cuentos de
moderación digo que esto pasa en chucky
pero en santa juana es peor el minero ya
no sabe lo que vale su sudor y arriba
quemando el sol
me volví para santiago sin comprender el
color con que pintan la noticia cuando
el pobre dice no abajo la noche oscura
poro salitre y carbón y arriba quemando
el sol
hoy
[Música]
y arriba quemando el sol
y arriba quemando eso
y para qué
i
[Risas]
[Música]